[Musique]
je suis donc sarah durée de marque je
suis enseignant chercheur en droit
public à la faculté de l'université
catholique de lille j'ai rejoint
l'université 133 en tant que rapporteur
de l'atelier europe et relations
internationales à raison de mon champ de
recherche d'une part et d'autre part à
raison des perspectives offertes par cet
atelier
autrement dit allier à la fois la
consultation citoyenne des adhérents et
la recherche universitaires à travers
les échanges menés avec les différents
élus que j'ai eu la chance de visionner
l'objectif c'était en fait de pouvoir
regarder l'avenir
depuis la fenêtre du centre une certaine
manière tous contre tous les échanges
qu'on a pu avoir et tout ce qu'on a dit
s'inscrire plus ou moins dans cette
ligne cherchent et qui revient à
chercher ce qui ce qui fait l'europe au
fond aujourd'hui pour les démocrates et
pour les centristes
à l'issue des différentes auditions cinq
pistes de réflexion ventes sont
ressorties la plus la plus importante en
volume que je dirais c'est relatif à la
place de l'individu dans l'europe
une deuxième piste de réflexion est
également ressorti quant à la place du
couple franco allemand dans le
l'évolution le développement des
relations internationales d'une part et
les relations européennes d'autre part
le troisième point essentiel qui est
ressorti de nos travaux c'est l'europe
de la défense qui semble qui semble être
la principale préoccupation pour les
adhérents si on regarde le l'enquète qui
a été menée en avril mai dernier le
sujet a été un sujet extrêmement
important dans nos échanges à travers
l'armée européenne mais également à
travers la politique qui doit être mené
avec nos voisins petit de voisinage en
particulier avec les états qui sont
aujourd'hui des états tiers
qui pour certains souhaiteraient adhérer
européenne est rentré dans cette grande
robe pour d'autres n'en vois pas
l'intérêt politique de voisinage donc à
renforcer à développer pour rassurer
conforter garantir protéger c'est ton
père et cette frontière extérieure
ça c'est quelque chose qui est vraiment
ressortir que j'ai encore prise la
quatrième thématique importante c'est
celle de la place de l'europe dans le
monde
l'europe en tant que médiatrice l'europe
comme instrument des solutions des
conflits mais aussi le rock comme
instrument de diplomatie d'influencé le
cinquième élément qui est ressorti de
nos échanges qui au fond est
transversale de toutes les autres
thématiques tient au fait que l'agenda
de l'europe n'est pas rempli autrement
dit les objectifs ne sont pas
parfaitement atteint on est on est
arrivé à la conclusion que si la paix la
recherche de la paix en europe avait été
prendre des parts de l'ensemble de la
construction y compris chez les
démocrates
on sait justement on en est arrivé à la
conclusion qu'il fallait aller chercher
ce qui ferait ciment à la place il faut
prendre soin de développer la formation
la formation l'information de renforcer
l'éducation renforcer les moyens de
transmettre ses valeurs a trouvé le
moyen de renforcer également la
participation des citoyens à cette
europe
tout faux
bonjour à tous tout d'abord un grand
merci aux équipes à la fois numériques
mais aussi aux équipes sur le fond et la
préparation de ce moment deux plénières
et bien sûr merci à françois bayrou et
le modem pour l'organisation numérique
de très original de notre site et
démocrates qui nous permet normalement
dans seulement de travailler mais
surtout aussi de se retrouver de nous
retrouver par ces temps si singulier de
torpeur qu'ovide et qui risquent eux
quoi qu'il arrive dans les semaines qui
viennent d'être véritablement durable je
voudrais tout d'abord faire un tour de
table rapide remercié les intervenants
de leur présence
sous cette forme et puis accueillir les
internautes
il ya ce site pratique que nous n'avons
pas besoin de masques pour dialoguer
entre nous et je voudrais ils se
connaissent tous mais je voudrais pour
les internautes les présenter rapidement
nous avons jean louis bourlanges qui est
ancien député européen président il
était président un moment donné de son
parcours européen de la commission des
libertés à laquelle pour laquelle j'ai
vraiment beaucoup j'ai eu beaucoup
d'attention et d'intérêt
et puis il est aujourd'hui député des
hauts-de-seine et membre de la
commission des affaires étrangères
merci jean louis d'être là je ne te voit
pas mais tu dois être là je remercie
philippe michel casbas were de nous
avoir rejoints aussi il est notre député
du var et il est membre de la commission
défense et forces armées marie-pierre
vedrenne qui est députée européenne et
qui est membre de la commission du
commerce international
christophe brute de l'air également
notre député européen qui est lui membre
de la commission industrie recherche et
énergie et jean marie beaupuy qui est
ancien député européen et qui est membre
du bureau du parti démocrate européen
notre parti européen qui est très
investie depuis toujours sur toutes les
questions donc touchant à l'europe et
notamment aux liens entre l'europe et
les citoyens européens
j'aurais eu beaucoup plaisir aussi bien
sûr à accueillir donc à notre plénière
sur l'europe
mon ami marielle de sarnez qui incarne
une forme de synthèse sur par rapport à
ses responsabilités tant au parlement
européen où elle a travaillé sur le
rapport de la réindustrialisation de
l'europe et qui est au coeur de notre
sujet elle a toujours eu au sein du
parlement européen beaucoup travaillé
sur les relations ue-chine et les
conditions de réciprocités matière de
réciprocité des échanges et là beaucoup
travaillé aussi sur les échanges
commerciaux avec les pays du maghreb et
notamment la tunisie donc à la fois elle
incarne le coeur de notre sujet comme
ancienne députée européenne extrêmement
investi mais aussi aujourd'hui comme
présidente de la commission des affaires
étrangères au coeur de l'assemblée
nationale et dont les travaux sont au
coeur de notre problématique
elle nous regarde sûrement et je la
salue au passage je vous prie aussi
d'excusés avant de démarrer geneviève
darrieussecq notre ministre délégué
auprès de la ministre des armées qui
malheureusement a à une mission hier
qu'il oblige à être à l'étranger ne peut
nous rejoindre
même pas numériquement alors europe sur
la voie de l'indépendance vous voyez
notre thématique vous comprenez qu en
une heure il sera très très difficile
d'aborder toutes les questions mais on
va essayer d'y parvenir tout en laissant
du temps aux internautes qui nous ont
j'espère rejoindre nombreux sur sur les
différents réseaux permettez moi quand
même d'ouvrir le débat en quelques
minutes sur ce thème
et d'évoquer
les rencontres que j'ai pu avoir lorsque
au cours des trois mandats que j'ai eu
l'honneur d'exercer au coeur du
parlement européen
j'étais à la recherche d'une europe
puissance d'une europe puissance
politique
apparaissant comme la seule option
jouable à mes yeux dans le monde brutal
qui est le nôtre en terme de sécurité de
défense de dépendance énergétique de
d'autonomie alimentaire de lutte contre
le terrorisme etc
on va sans doute évoquer certaines des
façades de ces thématiques et j'ai
embrayé souvent dans les rencontres en
prenant 1 le titre provocateur d'un
roman d'un polonais qui était covadis
qui avait rien à voir d'ailleurs avec
l'europe mais pour dire l'europe où
vas-tu ou quelques elle quel est
l'objectif est aujourd'hui au fond nous
sommes à un moment où l'europe a réussi
à changer peut-être de braquet sans
utiliser le cliché très usé de l'europe
n'avance que dans les crises mais qui
est quand même en partie vrai avec notre
pays très fortement à la manoeuvre sur
la question européenne et qui depuis de
longs mois travail habilement avec une
grande patience à surmonter et plus tôt
peut-être à dépasser les divergences
non seulement le faisant dans le cadre
de la relation franco-allemande on va
sans doute l'évoquer mais pas que parce
que le couple le fameux couple
franco-allemand est une condition
sinequanone de la force de l'europe mais
mes parts mais pas seulement
et notre pays qui travaille aussi à
établir des relations de confiance
construite dans la durée avec les pays
européens alliés amis pour répondre aux
défis de notre temps
alors autant après la guerre le projet
on peut même dire quand même l'ambition
la belle ambition des pères fondateurs
pour moi qui suis une fille des
frontières et d'une région qui a été
traversé pendant des siècles par les
guerres c'est c'est une étape
extrêmement important que cette première
étape vers la paix et la réconciliation
ou au fond on est et on était au travail
à la construction d'une oeuvre entre les
pays européens
en laissant au fond un certain nombre de
questions fondamentales de sécurité de
de sûreté de défense soit aux états
membres eux mêmes soit donc au niveau
international donc à des organisations
internationales l'otan l'onu etc alors
autres autant aujourd'hui dans le monde
tel qu'il va
les défis sont bien sûr encore intérieur
entre états membres et au niveau des
états mais il est beaucoup plus
important aussi d'avoir idée de l'
équilibre qu'il faut trouver dans notre
rapport au monde tant nos défis uno
challenge pour utiliser un terme à la
mode sont extérieurs et on peut
considérer que l'europe ait lait soient
condamnés à exister soit à subir la loi
des autres dans tous les domaines que
j'ai évoquée en début de propos donc et
qui constituent tous ces défis qui ne se
relèvent qu ensemble en créant une sorte
de nouvelle puissance qui ne peut
exister qu'à l'échelle d'un continent
c'est pas notre pays d'ailleurs la
population la france est très très
importante sur la planète mais on est au
fond grosso modo 1 % de la population du
monde et donc on pourra pas tout seul à
porter la force nécessaire à la tente
des citoyens et c'est pas dans la
recherche d'une sorte de
d'imaginaire autarcie française mais
plutôt dans une forme d'indépendance
européenne que nous pouvons faire face à
l'autoritarisme de la chine aux coups de
menton d'erdogan à aux difficultés de
l'agro liot séculaire maintenant du
moyen-orient des menaces voilées de
poutine pour ne citer pour ne pas citer
plutôt la décomposition des projets de
nos alliés naturels qui étaient les
états unis
alors puisque jean louis bourlanges nous
à nous à retrouver
je me permets de commencer par
l'interroger tu m'entends
j'entends plurial à la flûte alors
allume le micro donc ça va revenir tant
que moi or notre intitulé l'europe sur
la voie de l'indépendance
on évoque l'indépendance on parle
souvent de souveraineté le président de
la république parle souvent lui-même de
souveraineté européenne
et puis aussi on parle d'autonomie
européenne ou de puissance comme moi
j'ai utilisé ce terme alors sans entrer
dans un débat de juristes comme nous les
aimons et parce qu'on aime partir de
concepts définit bien défini peux-tu
nous éclairer sur la différence enfin
sur le rapport de l'indépendance à la
souveraineté
est-ce que tu peut éclairer notre
lanterne jean louis bourlanges ce que
vous m'entendez nous très bien bon très
bien moi je m'entends aussi hélas nawezi
parler mais je m'entends par les écoutes
bombay coup tout ce que tu as dit me
paraît frappé au coin du bon sens et de
et de la justesse
je pense effectivement que nous devons
être attentifs au fait que le projet
européen
vraiment profondément changé de nature
depuis une vingtaine d'années trentaine
d'années depuis la chute du mur de
berlin et l'effondrement de l'union
soviétique et que nous n'avons pas
encore réussi à accepter et assumer les
conséquences de ce changement de nature
disons que initialement la construction
européenne était une affaire introverti
qui visait à éliminer les germes de
discorde et de guerre entre les
puissances européennes et en particulier
entre l'allemagne et la france puisque
le rapport entre la france et
l'allemagne avaient empoisonné les
relations européennes sur une assez
courte période il faut pas confondre ça
avec toute l'histoire de l'union
européenne
c'est essentiellement le rapport la
l'intensité du rapport franco allemand
enfin se développe sur moins d'un siècle
sera à peu près depuis ça devra en 1866
jusqu'à la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale rien à voir avec les tensions
permanentes entre par exemple au
royaume-uni et la france mais qui ne
sont pas qu'ils sont là des luttes des
ennemis héréditaires mais d' ennemi
héréditaire qui sont héréditaires parce
qu'ils ne volent ils ne veulent pas se
détruire l'un l'autre
tandis qu'avec les allemands ça a été
très court mais c'était à la vie à la
mort donc on a eu un moment très
difficile
l'europe a été construite dans un
premier temps pour faire face à cela et
si vous voulez c'est un peu derrière
nous nous avons encore des problèmes de
paix et de guerre à la périphérie de
l'europe on a eu les problèmes
balkanique on a quand même toute cette
instabilité au tour des états
successeurs de l'union soviétique
mais globalement à l'intérieur du couple
de l'union européenne
les rapports sont évidemment pas s'y
fier je crois que peu de gens imaginent
même à travers la gamme m avec le break
site que nous allons entrer en guerre
entre nous en revanche nous sommes
maintenant soumis à une pression nous
sommes confrontés à une espèce de
révolution copernicienne qui nous oblige
à nous situer dans un monde dans lequel
nous nous subissons
des attaques très forte des menaces des
pressions également des opportunités
nous sommes dans un monde qui n'est pas
celui amis ennemis mais qu'est celui des
associés rivaux où chacun est à la fois
un associé et un rival et il faut
reconnaître que notre logiciel de
construction européenne initial n'est
pas adapté à cette situation puisque
notre logiciel c'était de faire de
substituer le droit à la force
or là nous sommes confrontés non pas
nécessairement à la violence mais en
tout cas à des rapports de force avec
les russes avec les chinois avec le
monde islamiste avec les états unis
nous sommes confrontés à des rapports
qui sont les rapports de force ils vont
donc penser notre construction
européenne en termes d'établissement
d'un rapport de forces et pas simplement
en termes d'établissement d'une relation
de droit deuxièmement le deuxième
deuxième principe du logiciel européen
initial c'était de considérer que c'est
un peu le cas le côté techno de jean
monnet c'était de considérer que ce qui
nous réunit c'est c'était la raison
c'est à dire que j'emmenais penser que
quand il ya un conflit il n'y a pas
forcément de conflit d'intérêts il ya
même pas de conflit d'intérêts du tout
selon lui il ya simplement une
incapacité à poser en termes adéquats
les les intérêts respectifs des uns et
des autres et à dégager un consensus
rationnelle
j'emmenais ne perçoit pas suffisamment
la distinction entre le consensus de
raison et la notion d'intérêt de valeur
la notion qu'ancienne si vous voulez
d'intérêts et des valeurs c'est-à-dire
de choix entre des arbitrages politiques
on est pro russe ou pro américain on est
on est pour la liberté et pour l'égalité
tout ça ce sont des choses qui ne se
réduisent pas à des consensus de raisons
mais qui sont l'expression de choix
fondamentaux et ça ça s'appelle la
politique par rapport au droit et nous
avons donc une très très grande
difficulté
à introduire dans nos institutions le
parlement européen y contribuer parce
que c'est une assemblée d'hommes
politiques
la commission a été conçue initialement
comme la négation de la politique comme
un collège de gens qui étaient à l'abri
des passions politiques mais en réalité
c'est devenu un collège de politique
le conseil européen et le conseil les
conseils des ministres sont évidemment
des institutions politiques mais nous
avons malgré tout énormément de
difficultés à faire des arbitrages a à
dire voilà nous pensons cela il ya une
majorité même une majorité large mais il
n'y a pas il n'y a pas forcément une
unanimité
donc il faut bien voir que les obstacles
sur la route de de 3e option sont forts
le troisième obstacle
c'est évidemment une méfiance absolue je
les ai dit au début en part en opposant
la force et le droit
mais d'une façon générale une méfiance
absolue à et l'idée d'une mobilisation
militaire policière de des moyens donc
tout cela est quelque chose de très
difficile à vivre et je dois dire que
les français ont toujours été dans la
construction européenne notamment d'el
traité de maastricht très favorable à
cette révolution copernicienne
les allemands ont énormément traîner les
pieds pour différentes raisons dont le
passé et dans lesquels le pass le poids
du passé joue évidemment un rôle
essentiel mais ce qu'on peut voir
contrairement à ce que disent beaucoup
de beaucoup de critiques de la
construction européenne et de la
relation franco allemande
c'est que en réalité les allemands
évoluent ils évoluent lentement mais il
évolué il évolue plutôt dans le sens de
nos propres préoccupations et notamment
la présidente de la commission
européenne qui a été mise la défense
dans son pays est très sensible à des
thèmes qu'on pourrait qualifier de
france et donc je crois que c'est une
première un premier élément de réponse
le deuxième élément de réponse et je
fais très rap
chamas avis c'est sur la question quand
même juridique importante
la notion de souveraineté d'indépendance
oui c'était ma vie et je compte sur le
très très bref
ou alors tu conviendras simplement
bonjour bien m'arrêter
non tu reviens de peinture sur sur la
question souveraineté indépendance ce
qu'on va la traiter évidemment et je te
repasserait la parole mais merci de
cette présentation qui est pas seulement
frappé au coin du bon sens mais
carrément magistrale pour poser le débat
à l'heure actuelle pour notre europe /
effectivement la force et le droit c'est
extrêmement important et très très bien
et très bien développé et moi je
voudrais faire rebondir justement
philippe michel casbas bois qui est
membre de la commission défense je viens
d'évoquer les responsabilités
antérieures de our souls à vandereycken
est qui et qui nous permet de rebondir
sur ton propos paix et guerre à la
périphérie de l'europe évidemment on va
normalement pas déclaré la guerre entre
nous même si on a du mal parfois à
s'entendre même sur l'essentiel
en revanche il ya des bruits de bottes à
la périphérie de l'europe alors michel
philippe pardon en matière de défense
comment jouer une partition
d'indépendance européenne
quant au fond c'est aujourd'hui pour
résumer être peut-être un peu brutal au
fond c'est la france qui constitue la
défense européenne aujourd'hui et encore
agrémentées par le départ
du royaume uni alors comment faire et
celle tuer si nathalie quelques minutes
seulement 3 bref merci de m'accueillir
bonjour mes chers collègues et et
bonjour à tous ceux qui qui nous suivent
j'espère que vous m'entendez un petit
signe de votre règne en confirmant que
je suis audible mais saison vas-y vas-y
toulon toulouse et nice ont elle repart
donc je m'inscris exactement dans ce que
tu viens là d'expliquer la défense ou la
l'intervention ou la force de réaction
européenne repose sur la france mais
aussi sur le royaume uni
parce que vous le savez la france et
l'angleterre sont les deux seuls
puissance capable de projeter dans le
délai le plus court qui soit des unités
pour une intervention d'urgence
nous avons des unités sur le départ en
france en angleterre ce qu'ils font que
si cet après midi mme décidons une
intervention dans l'urgence ce fut le
cas sur cent garissou serval et bien dès
demain nous pouvons assurer de
projection ça veut dire que s'il se
passe quelque chose
j'ai trop faim de l'europe aux portes de
l'europe dans des incidents graves comme
les a connu des guerres d'ukraine en
géorgie mots nous pouvons intervenir
avec les anglais avec l'aide aussi des
américains et de certains autres
partenaires
mais l' expertise sur cette intervention
elle est franco anglaise et ce point
très important parce que dans mon
développement
le couple franco-anglais est à la
défense et à la sécurité de l'europe
aussi important que de cliquer
franco-allemand pour les questions
politiques et d'économie
t aujourd'hui cela m'amène à une
première suggestion première demande
faire c'est que dans les relations
tendues que nous avons avec les anglais
l'heure actuelle à cause du bric site et
de leur premier ministre
je souhaiterais que nous restions
dans la philosophie de l'europe et la
bienveillance heureux nous soyons des
gentlemen pour reprendre l'expression
anglaise consacrer de manière à ne pas
être trop brutaux et gardez toujours à
l'esprit que nous souhaiterions qu'un
jour les anglais nous rejoignent à
nouveau parce que nous pensons tous que
beaucoup d'anglais le pense que ce break
site est une mauvaise idée et deux parce
que dans cette construction d'une
sécurité de l'europe d'une défense de
l'europe
les enquêtes les accords de lancaster
house qui unissent la france et
l'angleterre sont incontournables et
vont être renforcées d'autant plus que
je reprends ce propos me disait jean
louis pour l'heure tout à l'heure c'est
qu'un de nos autres alliés est en train
de faire défaut l'amérique de train vous
avez dit écoutez nous nous ne voulons
plus payer pour la défense de l'europe
je dirai toujours des moyens de
transmission de renseignements ils ont
mis à disposition mais qu'il faut pas se
leurrer si demain biden est élu ça ne
changera rien par rapport à la pression
que les états unis mettront sur l'europe
la pression commerciale la guerre
commerciale entre les états unis et la
chine font que les options stratégiques
des etats-unis se poursuivront
quel que soit le président des états
unis qui sera voté d'ici peu cela veut
dire quoi
c'est que dans ce monde qui est peuplé
d'ennemis les ennemis cedej c'est les
djihadistes ou de prédateurs pour
reprendre l'expression de françois
heisbourg dans son ouvrage sur les
prédateurs et nous les prédateurs ce
sont les chinois ce sont les russes sont
même les états unis sur cette guerre
commerciale
cela veut dire que aujourd'hui comme le
disait jean louis bourlanges très
justement autant la construction de
l'europe et de l'union européenne s'est
fait sur des fondamentaux sur des
ressorts qui nous ont permis de créer un
espace de paix à la porte duquel un
certain nombre de pays viennent frapper
nous l'avons entendu tout à l'heure dans
la périphérie immédiate de l'europe il
ya des états qui souhaiteraient devenir
européen
et on les comprend tous
nous devons donc aujourd'hui construire
par des alliances avec les anglais d
alliance renforcée lanka soit renforcé
et par une vision stratégique naissante
ou en voie d'amélioration de la par nos
collègues allemands qui va nous conduire
nécessairement à envisager cette cette
politique de sécurité de la défense dans
un délai court et à moyen terme
forcément au sein de l'otan parce que
vous le savez très bien et prenons à
l'image de la france qui est le pilier
de la défense de l'europe
nous tenons quasiment la défense
opérationnelle qu'un dans le stade de
france et ses abords alors qu'avec le
temps nous sommes 7 110 80 milles contre
les trois cent mille ruses il pesant 20
700 milles contre les 300000 russe
elle donne n'est pas la même cela veut
dire que aujourd'hui nous devons à tout
prix nous n'avons même plus le choix
qu'entre amis me disaient je veux plus
payer on pouvait se poser des questions
aujourd'hui nous devons le faire le fait
que l'otan est une zone de tension
aujourd'hui notamment avec ce qui se
passe en méditerranée l'étude ne doit
pas nous faire oublier qu'il ya toujours
eu des tensions comme dans toute
relation d'associer quand certains états
de l'europe contourne les sanctions
infligées à la russie n'a pas l'habitude
de les régler de manière diplomatique en
crise turc doit se régler de manière
diplomatique et nous devons oui nathalie
juste 4 des côtes oui philippe la
présente je suis obligé d'être je ne
suis pas maître du donjon trancher la
question
j'ai une responsabilité parce que on
doit garder du temps aussi pour les
questions des internautes
drake tout le monde ait pu déjà exprimé
un point de vue on entend bien
effectivement les défilés dilemme même
qui se posent à nous mais quand tu dis
nous devons nous devons est-ce que tu
parles d'une indépendance européenne où
tu parles de la france avec l'en le
royaume uni
face à face à nos nos adversaires parce
que il y a quand même un début de
quelque chose en termes d'indépendance
européenne avec le fonds européen de
défense qui a un peu été rabotée et
encore je crois que la discussion n'est
pas fini mais qui sortira de la
discussion budgétaire européenne un peu
raboté mais qui qui envisage en tous les
cas une mutualisation une une production
en termes d'armement qui soit européenne
et qui nous permettrait de finir cette
logique qui ne repose que sur la france
au niveau de l'union européenne et les
liens anciens et utile avec le royaume
uni
alors quand tu dis nous tu parles de la
france où tu parles des européens parce
que c'est vrai j'ai des origines parce
que nous n'aurons pas supporter l'effort
tout seul
les liens que nous avions vécu royaume
uni sont pas des tricots table à l'heure
actuelle oui on a bien enchaîné en
angleterre et et regardez bien aussi
qu'aujourd'hui l'angleterre fait l'objet
d'une prédation des états unis sur un
des opérateurs 5 g qui met les emmener
dans le même émoi que nous vis-à-vis des
etats-unis donc ils resteront des
partenaires logique
et aujourd'hui si cette évolution
stratégique j'en parlais jean-louis de
l'allemagne qui va nous permettre de se
concrétiser les avancées de l'initiative
européenne de défense
mais le temps que cette concrétisation
puis se déboucher sur quelque chose ça
veut dire que les supports
opérationnelles à court terme très court
terme comme la france et j'ai et le
royaume uni peu vont rester
incontournable mais nous ne pourrons pas
mais un effort prolongé tout seul cela
veut dire que l'europe aujourd'hui doit
se saisir de cette question ça veut dire
un budget adapté et une petite relation
entre les cultures en serre poids et
dans le cas où certains états européens
nous ont réunis de l'union mais pas tous
et c'est un sujet d'école qu'est ce que
nous faisons merci philippe de cette
excellente présentation et je profite de
tes propos et de ceux de jean-louis sur
l'allemagne pour passer la parole à nos
députés européens sur l'allemagne par
exemple je prends la situation le
peut-être le changement de pied dedans
gala merkel puisque vous avez et
jean-louis les toits par les deux aussi
des déséquilibres commerciaux
vous savez peut-être que toutes les
ménagères allemandes auront dans leur
cuisine un robot moulinette coupe
légumes kucka d'un producteur bavarois
qui vient d'être racheté par le chinois
midea et qui alors ça n'explique pas le
changement de pied d'un gai là mais
cette espèce de prise de conscience de
deux rivaux stratégique à l'intérieur du
marché intérieur et qui donc peuvent
peut-être réussir à nous sortir nombreux
delà de la naïveté un peu européenne qui
était sa marque de fabrique pendant tout
un temps et marie pierre et christophe
qui sont au coeur de ces sujets et qui
se trouvent être des sujets au coeur de
l'actualité avec
avec donc les le japonais bridgestone
dans le nord avec general electric avec
l'acier aussi et qui sont directement
concernés dans leurs travaux et dans
leur décision parce que je voudrais
qu'on parle aussi au delà de nos
analyses même si on a très peu de temps
de qu'est-ce que vous décidez de faire
et comment on concrétise
c'est ce momentum qui est celui de
l'europe en ce moment au niveau des
dossiers européens
le blocage de l'om sait les l'étude
d'impact qui a commandé douar philippe
sur l'ale sur les effets du mercosur sur
notre économie européenne avec des
constats très très négatif sur la
déforestation
donc à vous la parole peut-être
marie-pierre en premier quand quand
l'europe parle le langage la puissance
s'apprend quelle forme exactement
bonjour à tous
j'espère déjà que vous n'entendez bien
je suis ravi d'être avec vous retrouver
les collègues pour cet échange dont sur
un qui pour moi essentiel la question
qu'on nous pose aujourd'hui l'europe sur
la voie de l'indépendance c'est la voie
qu'il faut prendre et jean louis
bourlanges a bien contextualiser les
choses sûres at on déjà décidé de
prendre cette voie et comment va-t-on
l'emprunter alors le conte c'est parce
que je voulais mettre un poil aux
dérogations mois encore plus prendre
cette voie c'est une voie que porte la
france à l'échelle de l'union européenne
et maintenant c'est l'enjeu c'est
justement de convaincre tous nos
partenaires européens de l'emprunter
également alors tu le soulignes et
l'adami machy dans la commission du
commerce international et quels sont les
combats sur lequel on porte et quelle
vision on défend on défend la vision
d'un commerce mondial qui soit régulé
qui soit juste et qui soit durable
réguler d'abord ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que justement le commerce
international s'inscrit dans un contexte
rappelé par philippe de tension de
guerre commerciale
il faut employer les bons termes aussi
en vigueur commerciale et l'union
européenne est un peu le terrain de jeu
d'une rivalité chine aux états unis et
donc il faut que nous on dessine notre
propre voie et pour ça sur la scène
internationale il faut que l'union
européenne soit clair dans ses ambitions
elle doit porter la défense du
multilatéralisme elle doit porter la
réforme de l'organisation mondiale du
commerce est une organisation mondiale
du commerce qui maintenant compte des
règles et du contexte dans lequel on
c'est-à-dire bâti
une mondialisation qui soit juste on a
abordé depuis le début aussi de cet
échange
la perte de la chine on le voit bien à
l'heure actuelle ursula von der leyen
emploie maintenant le père de clivage
est stratégique
c'est véritablement le cas la chine est
un rival stratégique il y a des
relations qui sont basées sur une
concurrence déloyale en matière sociales
fiscales et environnementales
il faut que l'union européenne justement
au travers d'une mondialisation qu'ils
soient plus justes défendent une
concurrence loyale avec tous les
partenaires la chine les etats unis mais
c'est aussi tout l'enjeu des
négociations que nous avons en 4 dupré
xixes et dont on débattra demain avec
michel barnier
et puis il ya la question d'une
mondialisation qui soit durable
parce que on le voit bien le contexte du
bolide nous a démontré que nous étions
complètement dépendant de la chine ou
même de l'inde pour la production de
médicaments
il faut donc que nous ne soyons pas
dépendants à la fois d'acteurs étatiques
tels que la chine
mais à la fois d'entreprises si je
prends sur les services numériques notre
dépendance vis-à-vis des gaffes
il faut qu'ils aient des géants
européens qui émerge sur ces questions
là je pense que cette offre aura
l'occasion d'évoquer tout le travail qui
fait justement en matière industrielle
donc c'est toute cette volonté qui doit
se concrétiser avenant par des
propositions concrètes
donc moi ce que j'ai envie de dire
aujourd'hui à nos amis auditeurs et
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
tout le travail qu'on doit faire c'est
celui aussi de l'unité européenne
dans cette vision là parce que je le
disais en introduction la france porte
cette voix du nord' up qui s'affirme en
tant que puissance mais certains noms
partenaires ont parfois du mal à
l'assumer ont peur des représailles et
justement en matière commerciale et de
nouvelles impositions de droits de
douane donc ça veut dire que l'union
européenne en fait elle devance musclée
elle doit renforcer son arsenal
juridique pour se défendre et c'est tout
l'enjeu à moi d'en dossier que je porte
à l'heure actuelle qui s'appelle fr
régulation c'est le règlement sur
l'application des vagues en matière
commerciale
c'est faire en sorte que l'union
européenne elle puisse agir dans un
temps quand même assez le plus rapide
possible d'être efficace être cohérente
pour défendre ses intérêts au sein de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce est
dans ses accords bilatéraux tels que le
mercosur
alors d'accord rythme en galerie pierre
sennes franco impertinent temps il faut
construire les majorités à la fois au
parlement européen et maintenant on est
dans les négociations en phil ochs avec
le conseil pour ça oui alors
marie-pierre soyons concrets
effectivement parce que tu as très bien
poser le débat à l'heure actuelle avec
la prise de conscience de
des défis de la localisation des des
concurrents leur caractère sauvage sans
règle alors que nous nous poursuivons
des règles qui sont toujours pas très
bien connue des citoyens alors même
qu'ils aspirent à les avoir
donc ils ne les connaissent pas
concrètement puisque le groupe donc de
renew est un groupe qui a une force donc
bien supérieure à celle qui était notre
force dans les mandats précédents vous
êtes à la fois le groupe le plus
puissant au sein du groupe parlementaire
donc qui est lui-même le groupe central
pour les décisions et les pouvoirs alors
à la fois comment concrètement
maintenant vous aboutissez et puis aussi
quelles sont ces mesures très brièvement
mais rentrons dans le concret pour que
on dépasse le constat que on qu'il est
qu'il était tout à fait opportun de
faire je pense c'était très important
effectivement il faut rappeler que la
délégation aux naissances au sein du
groupe renault a là un rôle central dans
un rôle de pivot on a un rôle
d'aiguilleur au sein du parlement
européen et sans gros ligne où il ne
peut pas y avoir de majorité sur
certains sujets ça aussi il faut le
comprendre la logique du parlement
européen qui est très différente de
l'assemblée nationale quand on a des
positions sur les questions on va dire
l'europe sociale la transition
écologique on va avoir une majorité
plutôt à gauche et roniu et la
délégation de naissance fait la bascule
et puis sur d'autres sujets on va être
allié avec le parti populaire européen
mais aussi avec les sociaux-démocrates
donc c'est vrai que c'est une logique
différente et renaissance a vraiment ce
rôle fondamental mais pour ça ça veut
dire aussi qu'il nous faut travailler
avec tout le monde
les majorités se construisent à chaque
projet donc c'est aussi un travail est
un méticuleux pour veiller à faire en
sorte que nos positions soit celle qui
emportent la majorité au parlement et
que soient leur donne donc le concret
sur le dossier que je porte à l'heure
actuelle donc
brigue un sixième mandat et les
blogueurs brièvement le mans européens
plus vite possible au parlement européen
il a fallu derrière construit la
majorité en commission commerce
international et j'ai obtenu 32 voix sur
35 pour mon rapport à la base on avait
dit qu'il n'obtiendra rien mais j'ai
pris le temps d'échanger avec tout le
monde et de leur démontrer que si
l'union européenne veut porter cette
voix sur la scène internationale
il faut qu'on justement ce muscle qu'on
se renforce qu'on ait des nouveaux
outils juridiques parce que si derrière
on veut défendre justement cette voie de
l'indépendance
si on n'a pas ces outils qui nous permet
d'avoir un levier dans les négociations
avec des partenaires qui ne joue pas les
règles mais en fait on n'a pas fait
d'erreurs qui est suffisamment de place
on va dire dans notre cave et de jeu
donc c'est tout l'enjeu et je crois
qu'on y arrive et je pense que
christophe va voir maintenant justement
avec d'autres exor merci de lui passer
la parole effectivement sur la la la
politique industrielle qui est un outil
extrêmement important au jour
d'aujourd'hui est dans l'actualité
d'économie de notre monde christophe
comment situe donc par rapport à cette
question de l'indépendance à jour et
qu'on n'oublie chez eux ne perdent
jamais de vue la thématique de notre
table et software bonjour gut aline
bonjour à tous merci pour cette
plateforme
alors donc simplement l'indépendance que
ce que c'est fête de l'indépendance ça
veut dire très concrètement que l'europe
et son propre destin en main et ne
dépendent pas des autres à travers le
monde et indépendance a fait des fois
peur ça veut dire protectionnisme donc
c'est le gars protectionnisme ça veut
aussi dire pour nos amis libéraux
attaché au marché commun que c'est une
remise en cause lamentable de la liberté
du marché donc il faut vraiment faire
attention là dessus et ce qu'on en pense
plutôt au niveau européen c'est le
concept d'autonomie stratégique
autonomie stratégique qui tenait
d'ailleurs toujours pas acceptée par son
parlement européen qui nous parlent
parfois que la commission maintenant
d'une autonomie stratégique ouverte
bon l'autonomie c'est ce que c'est
l'ouverture aussi mais l'autonomie
ouverte voilà c'est un concept un peu le
feu un peu bull bruxelloise
il va falloir taper dedans pour que ce
concept ne reste pas trop longtemps donc
être maître de son destin c'est
notamment en matière de défense jean
brunhes 30 secondes sur ce qu'a dit tout
à l'heure
mon ami philippe les anglais l'avant
bretagne elle quitte l'union européenne
maintenant qu'on continue à 27
on va pas continuer comme avant et et
britanniques même s'ils ont
effectivement une armée très puissante
même si on va compter sur eux dans le
cadre de l'onu mais dans le cas de
l'union européenne et l'europe de la
défense
on va faire ce sont les britanniques et
progressivement on va faire sans l'otan
alors effectivement aujourd'hui il n'a
pas encore les moyens
bon mais la cohérence de ce fonds de
défense qui est à 9 milliards d'euros
quand même pour faire le scaf franco
allemand notamment mais aussi l'espagne
petit mais bon c'est un système
d'aviation d'aviation du futur avec les
drones pour faire le char franco agen
pour l'euro drones évidemment donc tout
ça ça ça va se faire sans les
britanniques
voilà donc on y et puis s'ils veulent
revenir un jour ils seront les bienvenus
parce qu'on les aime beaucoup mais je
crois qu'aujourd'hui fort le courage de
dire ceux qui sont dedans ils sont
dedans et c'est ensemble qu'on fait
quelque chose alors sur la partie qui
est le plus de la mienne c'est
l'autonomie industriel et technologique
on va dire sur lesquels il ya du boulot
faire parce que il ya des gros intérêts
on est comme le premier marché mondial
l'union européenne donc il ya des gros
intérêts des gros lobbys américains
chinois russes qui viennent nous
solliciter pour les thématiques
d'énergie ou de production industrielle
et il faut être très très vigilant pour
ne pas se laisser faire leur très
concrètement l'europe s'est rendu compte
notamment avec le comique avec de graves
lacunes de notre dans son tissu
industriel qu'on avait laissé partir des
choses en pensant que la matière grise
pourrait rester en europe et que la
production sera le bout du monde et on
s'est aperçu de l'impasse donc il ya des
outils très concret qu'on a mis ensemble
dans le cadre qu'on a mis qu'on a mis en
action dans le cadre du plan de relance
et du futur cadre financier pluriannuel
les alliances européennes par exemple
nous serons peine de lire eugène de la
batterie
la fin du mois des matières premières
ces alliances européennes sont une
dérogation qui permet à chaque état man
de subventionner les filières qui permet
également à l'europe de subventionner
ces filières normand c'est interdit dans
le cadre du dans le cadre du marché
commun et bien comme ça on va pouvoir
être certain d'avoir une autonomie dans
les médicaments dans dans l'hydrogène et
et c'est plutôt bien fait maintenant les
nouveaux textes
je prends l'exemple de l'hydrogène le
plan dit clairement qu'on va déjà
permettre de prod d'avoir des
producteurs d'oeufs de problèmes dans le
dos dans le transport des producteurs
d'hydrogène qui ont des kit moteur avant
de subventionner la production
d'hydrogène
pourquoi c'est plus malins eux quand on
subventionne la production d'hydrogène
après on encourage les investissements
étrangers comme on l'a fait pour le
photovoltaïque
on a voulu subventionner les panneaux
conclusion l'argent a profité aux
chinois aux coréens qu'ils sont nuls où
nous nous vendre leur que leurs panneaux
photovoltaïques qui était avancé alors
que notre industrie n'en avait pas donc
ça c'est des serments un outil très très
important le principe de réciprocité
le principe de faire compétition donc
les subventions d'état déguisé et dans
les autres états membres
enfin dans les autres parties du monde
ça doit pas fonctionner voilà sur
lesquels on se mobilise le commissaire
breton qui est en charge de ces
questions là est très très impliqué et
donc on fait un bon travail ensemble
entre le parlement et la commission
qu'on n'est pas d'accord on se le dit
mais voilà il ya un très très gros sans
enjeu on sait qu'ils pourront voir de
grandes de grands plans de licenciements
à l'avenir et donc l'europe a les moyens
on a mis le paquet financier pour
pouvoir redresser
c'est ce domaine industriel et donc
continuer à oeuvrer à une ans a fait des
belles déclarations comme ça en début de
mandat mais après il faudra du concret
pour voir ac et qui ment sur chacun des
thèmes comment on arrive à construire
quelque chose
merci christophe deux de ses éléments
très concrets qui sont en cours de
discussion et qui vont aboutir à des
décisions qui donneront une forme
concrète
une petite question très rapide
pour mai par oui ou par non christophe
est ce que par exemple on va fixer des
limites aux investissements étrangers en
europe ou bien ce serait
contre-productif mais en une phrase oui
on va fixer les limites note à 10 ans
voit ici délit mais qui vaut au respect
de l'accord de paris pour les questions
environnementales au respect de l'état
de droit ou si ça aussi c'est une valeur
qui monte quand même dans le nyong et
épuisant s'assurer que ces
investissements étrangers soient
également de l'argent propre
évidemment mais c'est eux mais les
étrangers seront toujours les bienvenues
pour investir de l'union européenne bien
évidemment mais il y aura quand même
grosse vigilance les règles de la
concurrence soient être vu donc elles
datent de 1997
vesta guerre a promis ça serait fait
dans les tout prochains mois donc on
attend dessus parce que maintenant oui
notre hantise européenne elle joue pas
sur le terrain mondiale donc on est sur
le global markets
comment marché global et c'est là dessus
qu'il faut mettre par examiner nous
venons règles de concurrence
merci christophe je te repasserait la
parole sans doute tout à l'heure si j'y
parviens parce que nous avons beaucoup
de questions des internautes
et comme le sujet très vaste je ne
pourrais je les avertis tout de suite
pour qu'ils n'entrent pas dans une
fraude frustrations profondes
je n'arriverai pas à faire en sorte que
vous puissiez traiter toutes les
questions j'en prendrai une sélection
alors justement marielle avait beaucoup
travaillé sur ces questions de
réciprocité et donc de respect des
normes ce sont des éléments qui
constituent les soubassements je pense
des travaux je voudrais passer la parole
à notre sage son regard de sage et de
dom serein donc à jean marie beaupuy et
je vais lui demander mais je sais qui
c'est être extrêmement bref comment on
l'y voit cette indépendance dans
l'interdépendance puisque
tous les quatre avant toi ont bien dit
que on n'était pas seul au monde on alès
musclé que on allait exprimer cette
indépendance ou cette force jamais cette
souveraineté vous aurez noté
pour l'instant tous les cas elle est
encore une spé et donc première question
à laquelle je souhaite une réponse très
concise la deuxième qui est sans doute
la plus difficile de notre table ronde
jusqu'à présent j'aime la provocation
c'est celle de comment on associe les
citoyens à ces défis comment on arrive à
dialoguer avec eux donc en confiance
jean-marie pour deux minutes voyage mais
à chaque étape c'est les drôles de à
est ce que je peux demander un
technicien de me couper ou alors je vais
me couper le son parce que l'arracheuse
j'ai un retour qui est désagréable donc
je vais vous m'entendez là oui je peux
continuer donc d'aller chers amis la
question débattue
derrière le titre d'indépendance et
d'autonomie a montré qu'en fait
l'indépendance intégral ça n'existe pas
l'autonomie intégral ça n'existe pas le
virus a montré que c'était une affaire
évidemment qui dépasse largement nos
frontières et qu'en fait dans ce monde
là jamais à l'échelle de la planète
la seule façon de pouvoir assurer une
forme d'indépendance c'est d'être très
forts soi même donc en fait la question
qui nous est posée à nous aujourd'hui
comment dans le monde avec non seulement
comme l'a dit philippe les questions
militaires mais aussi les questions
commerciales les questions de santé
les questions de recherche et heracles
comment dans notre monde la france
d'abord l'europe peut-elle être encore
plus forte
et puisque natalizumab aux deux minutes
seulement ce que je veux dire c'est que
je souhaite vivement que les 750
milliards à l'échelle européenne et les
100 milliards à l'échelle française
soit des outils qui vont nous permettre
dans le cadre d'une relance réel de
sauter par dessus les difficultés qui
sont déjà là et qui vont s'amplifier
dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent pour que effectivement sur les
sujets clés qui ont été validés par
l'europe tant au niveau de la commission
du conseil et du parlement
c'est à dire l'écologie la recherche et
sert à l'indépendance au niveau des
médicaments et autres que sur ces
domaines là au-delà des difficultés que
nous devons impérativement dominer dans
les six mois un an et d'un an et demi
qui viennent et bien l'europe prennent
un temps d'avancé
l'europe c'est bien sûr le couple franco
allemand
mais ce sera d'abord et avant tout notre
capacité de manière unie à être leader
sur ces nouveaux enjeux qui sont
planétaires et je les reprends pas parce
que cela a déjà été cité partiellement
et que nous aurons l'occasion d'y
revenir les citoyens
la question la plus dure sur le même
sujet m vous avez les moyens comment
associer les citoyens là personnellement
je je je c'est un sujet clé parce
qu'avec les réseaux sociaux ce qu'on a
vu en france et j'ai le nom de tera et
c'est vrai à l'échelle planétaire s'est
pas seulement vrai à l'échelle française
nous avons une grande difficulté mais je
pense que ce à quoi nous devrons nous
attacher
c'est d'abord de faire de la pédagogie
parce que trop de contre-vérités
involontaire se nourrissent d'une un
déficit d'informations et de
connaissances
les gens veulent sur les réseaux sociaux
notamment parlé de tout alors qu'ils ne
connaissent rien et ça ça s'apprend qui
m'a amené ces temps-ci si l'on veut ce
véritable débat citoyen il faut
recommencer déjà arestrup et ceux qui
veulent débattre du contenu des sujets
dont ils veulent débattre merci beaucoup
on va pas trop critiquer les réseaux
sociaux et les systèmes numériques parce
que c'est grâce à eux qu'on se retrouve
en tous les cas aujourd'hui avec plaisir
mais le temps passe de la même façon sur
le numérique dans l'oeuvre
vie et donc je voudrais passer la parole
aux internautes je ne peux pas gelé
vraiment je m'en excuse déjà auprès
d'eux a mené les toutes les questions
j'en ai choisi au fur et à mesure une
série alors une première question pour
marie pierre et christophe qu'il me kill
me m'excuser de les mettre ensemble en
binôme mais ils sont au coeur du
réacteur européen
quid de l'airbus du médicament dont on
parle c'est une question donc de 2,2 de
pierre krings je crois quid de l'airbus
du médicament une minute mème pas pour
répondre s'il vous plaît lors d'un
discret pas si ça fonctionne ah oui
merci merci nous mettre en binôme parce
que déjà en fait le sujet christophe et
moi sont extrêmement liés
plaidant pour répondre à cette question
avoir un airbus médicaments mais avoir
des airbus sur d'autres sujets c'est lié
à la politique commerciale pour assurer
justement davantage de réciprocité dans
nos échanges et c'est lié à une
politique industrielle qui doit une
forte et qui nous permettent de re
localiser justement certaines
productions
donc c'est tout le travail qui doit être
fait parce que la crise du coc vide que
nous traversons démontre bien justement
notre dépendance vis-à-vis de la chine
et vis-à-vis de l'inde par rapport à
certaines productions de médicaments
donc il faut qu'on travaille avec les
industriels pour pouvoir ont localisé
cette industrie et pour pouvoir aller au
tonneau il est souvent le fait on le
fait ou pas on est en train de le faire
ou on veut le faire
marie-pierre ont fait cet airbus du
médicament où on envisage de le faire
bien marie-pierre vous ne m'entendez via
les uns et les autres c'était une
question de camille petitjean d'ailleurs
j'ai retrouvé entre temps marie-pierre
on le fait ou on veut un jour le faire
alors je sais pas sûrement temps du coup
et vivaz nicole par ces bruits on entend
là
il ya alors inutilement mais sont
beaucoup de sujets il ya une volonté
ensuite il va falloir s'il ya la volonté
politique et puis la réalité
et puis là tout le travail qu'on doit
mener avec les industries et les indes
et toutes les entreprises sur ces
territoires
donc il ya plein de sujets et christophe
évoqué a par exemple tout à l'heure les
batteries là il ya tout ce qui a trait à
loudes rosel aussi il ya des
véritablement des avancées plus précises
sur certains sujets mais je pense que
t'as pas plus de réponse est oui
christophe justement on a parlé de ré
industrialisation je ne vois plus
christophe il doit être par là est ce
qu'on a
est-ce qu'on a les moyens et répond aux
demandes du médicament oui mais il faut
aller vite parce que je veux prendre
beaucoup de questions et en même temps
de la réindustrialisation ses résidants
de la région grand test au niveau de
leurs oeufs on ne parle pas de l'airbus
du médicament on parle par contre
effectivement de peut-être qu'au niveau
de la chimie au niveau des gens à des
matières premières on va mettre tout ça
en synergie mais c'est pas une
organisation spécifiquement type alliant
du médicament avec des subventions
nationales etc qui va se mettre en place
c'est une autre organisation dans le
cadre d'un programme santé de l'union
européenne et donc n'oublions pas
quelque chose c'est un peu l'incohérence
des x men où on est centriste donc on
peut nuancer les choses si on relocalise
du médicament dans l'union européenne
ça veut dire que notre relocalisation
elle sera pas forcément écologique
elle trace stratégique le reproduire
aujourd'hui de médicaments c'est
forcément polluer un peu plus en europe
un peu plus de délits adjoint de carbone
c'est de la chimie donc et ça on a des
fois du mal à admettre on veut mettre du
sang pour sang environnementale pour la
relance faut admettre que pour l'instant
eh bien oui d'un point des stratégies qu
on a besoin aussi d'avoir des
médicaments produits dans l'union
européenne et pas laisser hypocritement
d'afr se produire au bout du monde
de sorte que l'on n'ait pas pendant
pendant les pandémies merci pour
philippe s'il m'entend une question
d'hervé balle un internaute qui nous
pose là est la question épineuse mais
est très importante et qui est une
question qui parle aux citoyens vraiment
quelle relation devrait selon vous à
voir l'europe avec l'asturian non
stratégiques aux frontières extérieures
de l'union
nous devons avoir avec avec la turquie
une une attitude à la fois fermes pour
empêcher ce était en train de se faire
c'est à dire une frontière le qui
partirait de la turquie jusqu'à la libye
et qui partageraient la méditerranée en
deux globes le côté occidental côte
orientale que erdogan qui est un
personnage redoutablement intelligent
essaye de s'accaparer les deuxièmement
nous devons au niveau de l'europe
avoir un discours avec la turquie qui
rattrape l'erreur mais je dis vraiment
l'erreur d'avoir fermé d'avoir claqué la
porte au nez de la turquie au moment où
nous l'avons dit non bien sûr que nous
ne pouvions pas élargir l'europe au
niveau de la turquie mais entre dire non
et non mais il y avait un cap
énorme et il fallait que nous trouvions
un mécanisme que nous trouvions une
façon de pouvoir dire et je reprends une
expression gendry bourlanges aux turcs
nous ne pouvons pas mais nous savons
vous êtes les meilleurs des autres
pourquoi parce que nous sommes en train
de pousser erdogan et la turquie qui
s'appuie sur la partie anatolienne de la
turquie vers l'iran vers tes d'autres
prédateurs et nous devons aujourd'hui
renouer et nous appuyer à la fois sur
les européens et turcs européen ce
qu'ils viennent des balkans et que nous
ne ne vont pas comme avec les anglais
comme avec n'importe qui d'autre couper
les liens nous devons avoir des
discussions structurée de manière à
garder un contact et préserver la paix
aux portes de l'europe
ok merci philippe je reviendrai sur la
turquie en repassant la parole tout à
l'heure à jean-louis si nous entend
toujours
mais il ya encore une question de
camille petitjean a pour philippe je
pense qu'ils s'interrogent sur l'idée de
construire une armée européenne plutôt
que de compter sur nos alliés extérieurs
c'est à la suite du début du débat un
don qu'elle rebondit et sa question est
très bien et pertinents très bien pour
construire une armée il faut dessiner
une arme une armée c'est une culture
même en france on n'a pas pu créer une
quatrième armée était celle de l'espace
on l'a accolé à l'aviation à l'armée de
l'air pourquoi parce que construire une
armée c'est une culture qui est
historique et avec des ressorts des
fondamentaux pour aller au combat
on peut mobiliser une armée nationale
parce qu'on peut comprendre que des
jeunes veulent s'engager elles soient
prêts à donner leur vie pour protéger
leur pays afin de pouvoir créer une
armée européenne
il faudra que l'europe soit suffisamment
concrètes et fortes pour que des jeunes
européens puissent s'engager dans une
armée européenne afin de dire je suis
prêt à mourir pour l'europe nous sommes
moins culturellement de cette condition
nécessaire et budgétairement donc
construire une armée européenne
à mon avis à court terme c'est exclu à
long terme ça reste possible et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous ne pouvons pas
nous passer
d'aucuns des partenaires que nous avons
à l'heure actuelle afin de garantir
notre sécurité
si elle est un jour vulnérabiliser d'où
l'intérêt et ne pas penser que les
propos que nous avons christophe et moi
sont contradictoires c'est qu'il ya une
immédiateté
je suis dans la projection et christophe
et dans la moi je suis d'un projection
militaire et lui il est dans la
projection politique et sur un long
terme on pourrait créer une armée sur un
court terme ce n'est pas possible
ok merci philippe mais toute façon on
peut tous faire plusieurs choses à la
fois
même dans l'action et dans la réflexion
on peut
mené des choses en parallèle et c'est
c'est aussi l'intérêt de la politique en
s'adaptant à l'actualité à la tente des
citoyens alors comme il nous reste
quelques minutes
tout d'abord toutes mes excuses auprès
des internautes auxquelles nous n'aurons
pas réussi à répondre mais je propose
qu'il nous envoie les questions et la
deuxième chose que je voudrais bien
avant de repasser la parole à jean louis
pour conclure si nous entend toujours
j'espère qu entre temps ils s'organisent
pour que son micro fonctionne c'est que
moi je pense que ce serait pas mal qu'on
arrive à faire un petit mémo des
éléments intéressants de notre débat
puisque en 1h bon c'est ça passe ça
passe en un éclair donc ça serait bien
qu'on essaie d'avoir une trace de cela
alors j'avais dit que je rebondirai sur
la turquie
jean louis jean marie et moi même on
était présent au moment où on a demandé
au parlement européen de de voter en
faveur de l'ouverture des négociations
de l'entrée de la turquie dans l'union
européenne après les années qu'elle
avait passée de préparation à cela il ya
eu un vote de mémoire c'était le 17
décembre 2004 on a voté contre mais nous
étions minoritaires pour la france
d'ailleurs à l'époque la droite et la
gauche plaider pour couvrir les
négociations et je rejoins tout à fait
philippe en disant que bon au fond c'est
pas la peine de pleurer sur le lait
renversé la turquie c'est c'la c'est la
porte entre l'orient et l'occident et il
vaut mieux réussir à dialoguer et à ça
peut-être qu'il faut comme avec le
diable prend d'une longue longue
cuillère pour discuter avec erdogan on
le voit tous les jours que dieu fait
mais c'est très très important de garder
un contact sans pour autant donc la
turquie n'entre dans l'union européenne
qu'en pense jean louis et en même temps
je lui mets une autre question qui n'est
pas directement liée à celle de la
turquie mais qui permet de conclure
peut-être notre table ronde
c'est une question de
un internaute pierre coisne ce qu'ils
demandent où qui souligne je lis ça
question la gouvernabilité et donc
l'indépendance de l'europe parce que je
voudrais qu'on continue de parler de
traiter de cette question qui est kiné
qui est encore ouverte
ne sont elles pas profondément lié à la
sacro-sainte unanimité qui bloque les
nombreuses décisions gouverner à
plusieurs c'est savoir faire des
compromis mais aussi avancé malgré ce
qu'ils veulent freiner sa progression
pour conserver certains avantages ou
certaines postures politiques
allons-nous réussir à faire évoluent
évoluer cela merci de votre réponse
alors jean louis en forme d'apothéose de
la table ronde
un mot sur la turquie et deux mots et
demi sur cette question la règle de
l'unanimité
oui sur la turquie sur la turquie
nathalie ce qui me paraît ce qui me
paraît quand même frappant c'est
l'incroyable légèreté avec lesquelles
les européens en 98 si je me rappelle
bien au conseil européen d'helsinki ont
ouvert la porte à l'addition
vraiment il n'ya pas eu une minute de
réflexion il n'y a pas eu une analyse
des conséquences qu qu'on soit pour ou
contre
c'est évident que l'entrée d'un pays
aussi massive est aussi différent des
autres pays européens
poser un problème de redéfinition du
projet dans son mensonge et tout ça il
est évacué
on avait d'un côté des fraudeurs qui
avaient des électeurs turcs puisqu'il
est il changer un peu le système de
nationalité et il voulait faire un geste
en faveur de ses électeurs
jacques chirac qui était toujours
attardé à la lecture de lempire des
steppes de rené grousset qui avait
enchanté sa jeunesse et qui m'a marqué
ce qui marchait sur les pas d'anvers
pacha à la conquête du touron il y avait
les grecs qui ont estimé de façon
extrêmement téméraire qu'il fallait
renoncer à aa être opposé aux turcs en
espérant en contrepartie un règlement à
leur avantage de la question chypriote
tout ça a été vraiment et les
britanniques qui estimait que c'était
très bien à l'époque nous reprocher de
nous ouvrir ces pays et les
aucun pays musulman en réalité c'est
très pur
parce qu'ils y voyaient un signe
d'affaiblissement l'union européenne
absolument c'est comme ça que cette
affaire a été mené je me paie ga retour
ainsi je sais pas si c'est pour s en
débarrasser
mais c'est comme ça que cette affaire a
été menée il est évident que ça ne
pouvait donner que des résultats
catastrophiques que des résultats
absolument catastrophique et ça a été ça
a été le cas je ne suis pas de ceux qui
pensent que les bien sûr on arrive après
freiné parce que rien de marché dans
cette négociation
mais je pense que de toute manière
erdogan était à jouer un jeu être marqué
par une extrême duplicité parce que en
réalité il s'est servi de l'union
européenne pour au nom des droits de
l'homme etc a éliminé l'état profond
militaire justice et cetera kémaliste
qui était soutenu par les américains
et ça lui a permis à l'utiliser la libye
la libye lé de l'europe pour se
débarrasser de ceux qui des éléments
laïque de la société turque donc a
ensuite quand cet effet il a ici il a
dit bon tout ça c'était très bien mais
que lui ce qui l'intéressait c'était les
frères musulmans et l'empiré ottoman
donc je crois que là on a été dans un
marché de dupes
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce
qu'a dit suivi plus à l'heure c'est le
les turcs sont un grand pays il faut le
traiter comme un grand pays
mais c'est un pays extérieurs à notre
projet dans ça veut dire une chose en
tout cas on n'a pas du tout réfléchi aux
conséquences ex-agent de critères de
copenhague à nouveau à retour
oui il ya le copenhague
on y en est un pour les conduits selon
jean louis jean louis à la volée à la
fin était absolument essentiel merci à
tous merci à marie pierre à christophe à
jean louis bourlanges bien sûr à jean
marie beaupuy et un philippe de leur
participation nous restons un peu sur
notre faim mais ça appellera un autre
débat on est en en quémandant le fait
d'avoir une heure trente quand nous
sommes aussi nombreux
merci à toute l'équipe du modem merci à
françois bayrou on espère que marielle
nous écoute et que ça nous permettra de
poursuivre au moins par le biais
d'internet avec les internautes sur les
questions merci à tous et ne manquez pas
de suivre le reste des plénières et des
débats de la cité démocrate